this is ubiquito this is the conversion
of waste let's start from waste this is
the waste that you throw on your on your
on your bean right we chop it this way
all the grains organic all the color
these plastics
and the paper and cardboard we convert
this into this with our
process technology ubq we will sell this
material
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillary stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm honored to be joined today
by
tato biggio and we're going to be
talking about impact sustainability and
everything in between
tatu is co-founder and ceo of ubq
materials redefining household waste as
a valuable material feedstock for the
manufacturing industry
prior to ubq he co-founded and managed
meirav renewable energies
where he developed and implemented
large-scale wind solar and bio-ethanol
projects around the world
before selling mre in 2008 tatu served
as the president and ceo of ample
american
israel corporation an investment company
traded on both the nasdaq and the tel
aviv stock exchanges
a native of lima peru biggio grew up in
the shores of the pacific ocean with the
passion of diving and sailing which he
carries until today
tata bicho welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
very good michael thanks you know i i
have to start with a funny joke once
every 200 episodes i forgot to start
recording and so
we we had a great time until now and
we're gonna we're gonna do this again
but i i
i'm really honored and excited to have
you here with me when i get whenever i
talk to somebody who's working in the
climate and environmental space
and impact leader i i get you know i get
tingles because
you know this is where the world is
headed and it's so easy to get blinded
and and go
to the to the to the sexy and look at
the things we're seeing on tv all the
time but
throughout your life you've really made
it a mission of yours to focus on
climate and environmental change
but from a very entrepreneurial and
innovative perspective
now with ubq materials but previously
with different companies
and and i want you to take me back to
your journey starting from peru
and what i really want to get out of
this is to understand
what does it take to become a thought
leader in the
climate and environmental space and
doing it before it becomes mainstream as
it is today because you've been doing it
for quite some time
right okay thank you
in my case i was lucky because i was
raised
very close to nature actually our house
was in
in front of the ocean so i spend most of
my
of my life in the water not in land you
know and
not stepping on land except for school
um and in a way you get connected
to to not only to the water but to the
surroundings
uh and the quiet and the peace and the
also the wisdom of the ocean to tell you
uh
so uh in a way it gets into you in uh
it's part of your dna
uh and you carry it all your life um
then then of course
it's it's all about a matter of
character
and you know the way to approach things
uh i was i think 12 years old and the
school
director called me and he said listen uh
you
you you're intelligent you are just
doing enough
to pass your exams but you have a
problem
because you have a you're a leader and
people are looking after you
so you have a responsibility and
it means that you have to stay you know
to try to
step out of the pack and be a good a
positive
a positive image to to
to kids uh how old are you at this point
i'm i'm i'm i'm
10 12 years old wow yeah and the
and he's telling me listen uh you know
you have you you have a pack of people
watching you and
and and that's that's important you
should note it
uh that it's upon you so you know what
i have a question why how how do you
explain the fact that a teacher comes up
to you at 10 or 12 years old and tells
you
you ha you are a leader inside what what
happened
that he saw from the side that you're a
leader
well i think that that
he saw a guy that was typically very uh
you know very active and athletic and
a good student not because i was
studying it was because i i could i
could make it you know
and i was a very um approachable uh very
friendly
i really like people i i never like
elites
i was very open-minded and
he was a very special person by the way
he is considered one of the
one of the big educators in latin
america it happened that
he became okay uh he was minister of
education
after a few years so i was lucky you
know that
i had a role model on top of me
looking at those characteristics that
for him were important
and and taking me at that age was a
was something unique what does this do
to a 12 year old boy or kid
that you're being told that you are a
leader and you you
have a responsibility on your shoulders
uh in my case it it stroke a nerve
i have to say it did i i understood i i
processed it
so i immediately started studying more
being a better student you know i
i would go to the young movement and i
immediately wanted to take
leading roles and then i became of
course
like a guide and i started being
central in the in the organization of
the in the school for example they
you know in the in the union of of kids
it took me that way so then when when i
was
17 in a way i felt that that
i wanted just a little to open my my
wings
and it was lucky that my parents were
were
were the kind of people that said
whatever you feel is good for you is
good for us
and choosing israel as an alternative
to to create a future and come and study
you know you have a very good academic
level in israel
and it was part of that journey right uh
which started probably at 12 years old
incredible so
you're coming to israel to study the
hebrew university
walk me through some more milestones
leading up to
wanting to be an entrepreneur in in the
sustainability and impact space
okay so so uh the entrepreneurial part
is
is is definitely a little defining that
in that period because
uh imagine that you're coming from a
country that is
you know in the shores of the pacific
ocean
uh speaking spanish different food
different language different culture
uh you know the way that people approach
each other
is different the music is different and
the you know the language the language
is a big
big barrier i came here with very very
little hero that's the language here
so um i had to fight my way you know
uh to become part of uh of
of a society which i really didn't know
and
to learn the language and also to excel
in my in
in my studies in a way you know you have
to
cross a lot of bridges with a lot of
saliva and patience uh an effort
and in a way you know it
it prepares you for for the big moments
right
it's a journey that it's not not easy
but once you make it you feel so
rewarded
that then you understand that challenges
are actually good
and that if you uh in a way
focus on on your tasks uh
and don't lose your way you you are
always yourself
you will probably you will probably
succeed uh so that was
that was a recurring thing in my life
paint me the picture of what the world
looks like
in terms of you know the space that
you're in we're talking about
materials we're talking about climate
and the environment
what what what is happening because i
think this context is crucial still
today
with a lot of misinformation what is
tangibly happening around the world
and and and then i'd love to understand
how how do you fit into this picture
right right so so if we if we if we if
we move from from there
to to establishing ubq i will tell you
what is the rationale that
that took us to this to this journey
okay think about waste
think about the environment and think
about materials three
three circles okay waist is
is quite a negative thing right
materials
are good for people are good for society
for
you know for our way of life but they
are
they're very costly because we're using
natural resources and so we're depleting
our planet so yes we get materials but
on the other way
there are resources that don't that are
being uh
taken off right and then you have the
climate okay and the climate is shouting
for many years that there is there is
some problems here
waste climate and the and materials
don't don't don't don't get along with
each other because at the
end of the material goes to waste bad
thing waste impact the environment okay
when you create when you manufacture any
material you impact the environment that
triangle
doesn't work they each one is an issue
and they don't solve their problems they
each one increases the problem of the
other you understand what i'm saying
the more materials the more impact the
more weights the more weights the more
cla
okay so imagine now that you start
thinking okay let's take this circle the
circle and let's put them together and
then you have
your mathematician and every one of us
knows this intersection
and can you imagine what would happen if
waves climate and materials become
a blue instead of a red
where making material is actually saving
ways
and improving the environment it
it sounds quite remarkable right
so and the more materials you make with
this with this technology you're saving
more waste and you're saving more carbon
emissions
and the more you you do this the more
these circles
we interact with each other if
eventually we could
create ubq out of all the ways
uh we would have three circles one on
top of the other and a very blue
ocean in front it's it sounds a little
bit too good to be true but walk me
through
a walk me through a specific example of
of how this
is being translated into my life right
so i is a consumer
in the daily world how does ubq you know
change the way that i as michael
interact with the world around me in
terms of my pollution and my waste
management
perfect so mike imagine uh let's take
you from your house
you you eat your food okay you finish
dinner uh you have a few envelopes some
plastics of course some food waste
uh uh uh you drink your meal you drink
your yogurt you eat your yogurt
everything goes to the waste bin
and from then on you're happy because uh
you know something will happen but there
is some truck picking things and
that will go to a landfill right now
when that waste will go to a landfill
first of all
materials that you just once used once
like you know like this yogurt cup that
took you 30 seconds to finish your
yogurt is
out of the market okay all the materials
all the work all the energy that was
invested
in that cup is now in the cemetery of
ontario right
it's a waste the organic material that
accompanies this or your salad and every
all the stuff you throw your hamburger
left over
will decompose in landfills into methane
why because anaerobic uh biological
decomposition creates methane methane is
was one of the most
powerful gases in the planet so one of
the big issues of of
landfill is not only that they smell but
it's water leachates
it's the damage they do to the general
environment but most of it is the
methane emissions that they create
five percent of the emissions come
from from methane and landfills are a
very important part of it
so we have a problem with waste right
we're depleting natural resources
and we're creating methane emissions
okay
so that is one thing that you're doing
and if if someone could take that waste
and avoid before it's done filled okay
it's a composition you're doing
something extraordinary you are
taking materials that were going to the
cemetery and bringing them back to life
so what does unique you do we take that
waste
and we convert it into a thermoplastic
material what does it mean it's like a
kind of a new plastic
okay the plastics are made out of oil
remember plastics are made out of oil
these polymers polypropylene
polyethylene polyester in nylon
which you know are all made of oil now
imagine you take waste
and instead of reusing oil you convert
that into
a thermoplastic material that can
replace oil-based plastics
quite remarkable right so now you're
saving natural resources because you're
saving oil
which is cursed and expensive and now
what can you do with it
well you can do this is ubq
this is the conversion of waste let's
start from waste this is the waste that
you throw on your on your bean
right we chopped it these ways all the
grains organic all the color these
plastics
and the paper and cardboard we convert
this into this with our process
technology
ubq we will sell this material which
look exactly like polypropylene
polyethylene polyester
in the form of pellets to the existing
manufacturing industries and without the
need of
for them to change machines or change
processes okay
just like a dropping material they will
create an improv
so for example we will sell these to the
manufacturers of mcdonald's
so that mcdonald's can do these strains
okay now this screen is made out of uvq
material
which means that this is made out of
waste
so here you have chicken bones banana
peels
cardboard paper okay wow
and you're saving natural resources but
the most important thing that you're
doing here is that by buying
these mcdonald's by by producing these
trades with ubiq material they're saving
waste so they're saving methane
emissions
so they're saving a climate impact so
you have a you have a circular
system that is positive in every step of
the way
so it's a so it's a win-win-win now you
know as a very
you know i'm not not not educated enough
in the space you know when i think of of
recycling and when i think of waste
management on
a personal level and a lot of times i
think you know from behavioral economics
perspective how do we
how do we get to accumulate you know
grand change for society
not just with the one percent that are
pushers you know one of the things that
i always thought about was
you know just this idea that you have to
keep differentiating okay plastic to one
bin glass to another bin food to another
bin
and then and then you know it's such a
complicated process
that my brain can't even understand i
just know there's one bin and i just put
it there
what you're saying is that you actually
are understanding this
you're able to take all of this
composition of different materials
and convert it to something that's
usable so that i as a consumer
really don't have to change much in the
way that i live my life
that's absolutely correct and if you're
going to be still separating some of the
plastic the carbon and the paper
we will applaud you we will ask you to
keep doing that
because all because that can be recycled
again the plastic into plastic
but the residual waste will typically
end up in london that's not the majority
because in the world only five percent
at the end of the day is recycled by the
way
in in in the united states only 20
percent so the majority will
end up in landfill that is what we use
we will never
take whatever is recyclable on the
contrary
okay so we in a way are complementing a
recycling industry
with a end solution okay that takes care
of the materials that nobody wants that
will end up
damaging the environment which is what
i'm understanding from you
it's between 80 and 95 of
of the things that are being thrown out
in the world correct that's absolutely
correct
that that's a pretty fantastic market
now you're creating ubq materials
you're you're running this organization
you know walk me through some of the
some of your understanding of either
consumer behavior or the challenges
within this industry as you've been
there for quite some time now
the the
the general public okay has become
extremely aware of climate change
uh generation 8 generations did are
super inclined to to do something for
the world
you've seen all these manifestations in
the last two years
uh this little girl helga promoting in
the united
nations but it's already a world
consensus
that we do have a problem we're feeling
it okay we're feeling it
uh and then that is when
when when change comes when the
consumers
impose to brands to manufacturers
okay to companies that if they don't
change the way they do things
and don't become greener sustainable
they will not
source their materials they will not buy
those products
then they oblige these companies to make
a shift an immediate shift and once
governments on top of it
start getting into the game by imposing
taxes
on on on you know on carbon emissions
or by imposing that at least 30 percent
of the content of a product has to be
recycled
or recycled materials then you have a
a very strong um
you know like boom it's like a and we're
living that
actually we're now living that consumers
have already said their word
uh brands are following governments are
imposing
and from their own manufacturers
compounders and resin producers all the
chain value chain
is changing is changing the way they're
doing things
because if they are not green they just
will not exist so the new economy
is really coming in and the old economy
is going out as you may see
even indexes in the stock exchange are
bringing out all the economic companies
and bringing in
the sustainable ones which is fueling a
new economy
and basically that's happening now and
this because
this is good news to us to all of us and
and i love that the conversation starts
from
you know the sustainability and impact
of the of the world moving to consumer
behavior
to the technology but but really a
critical piece of it is the timing and
how
and and why this is the right time to be
leading a company like ubq materials and
and i'm really inspired by you know by
this type of work so really thank you
for coming on and for sharing with me
in these 20 minutes and your insights
and that's why i'd love to spend the
last few minutes i have a few more
questions about you
not about waste management but about
your own life so take me back to your to
your childhood
even maybe before before you are being
crowned a leader
which i i can't imagine how big of an
impact that has in a kid
what what really fascinates you what
really drives your curiosity
i am i am a very curious person i am
always exploring things i'm always
reading
i'm uh when i open the tv i will see
national geographic and i will
i will see how do you how do you do
things you know all these all these
things from from early age i was very
curious
um i mean the grand scale of things
uh i always thought that that that that
you know in order to make a change you
just like i told you before you you need
to do your part
and be a little lucky um so that is what
what takes me to be probably what i am
and what inspires you today
my kids that was easy i love it and what
are three words that you would use to
describe yourself
er i am open-minded
i'm very optimistic and and then i'm
very engaging
i i contacted people
i love it in the positive way of course
thank you very very much i look forward
to visiting you know in the south of
israel i've seen
the video phenomenal phenomenal work and
and it sounds really exciting and thank
you for all the amazing impact you're
doing on the world and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you
thank you michael you're definitely
invited to see our plant
taking waste and converting into into a
new climate positive material that
hopefully will change the world very
invited
take care bye-bye
[Music]